hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
right now i'm standing in ponte frat
right near wakefield
i want to introduce you to my favorite
rugby players on the planet
got my man jesse and q man what what are
you voting for
casper tigers oh and keithley keithley
cougars i've not heard of keithley
you're going to heal them now here's the
thing right these guys these guys
learned about service departments
you know you came to crash course a few
years ago started building their
portfolio
stepped into service departments rent to
rent and they were like actually you
know what
you don't need to just rent a property
you can go straight to a developer
and rent a whole block so so so we're
standing outside the cube
the cube what's up so tell me about this
what what's happening
let's go man this is 12 apartments
there's one two better but we're going
to show you around
all right okay okay show us around
[Music]
pretty much the cube is full i think
we've got two rooms that are available
right now so it's like a hotel
so it's like yeah similar to a hotel
where you get a you get a kitchen and
obviously the space is a lot bigger than
hotels oh it's better than a hotel right
so there's 12 12 apartments yeah 12
apartments
you're controlling the entire building
yeah man let's go around
let's go look welcome this was just a
normal
um just a normal key um door to get open
for key
but obviously um with the amount of
guests that will come that are coming in
and now
we needed to put in uh like a security
system so we used this last night you
know when we got here yeah oh did you
yeah we used this yeah yeah yeah so you
got to put in the code obviously i won't
tell you the code now
what's with the what's with this in the
communal areas
so that's our wi-fi so that's that's
mesh wi-fi
yeah so all it is you you get one or two
um
routers put in okay and then you just
buy a
mesh wi-fi because there's one of these
in my room as well yeah is this like a
communal wi-fi or something or is it
it just gives a better signal to these
okay
yeah um so which ones are available can
we can we have a look
but that one opens up as soon as the
firearms go off yeah that opens up
automatically
what how can you get how can you would
you get through that would you just have
to jump real high
just talk like just just just tell me
that just get tested
you'd be almost tormenting wouldn't it
just thought we'll show this this part
of the system-wise checking so we don't
have to come in and literally check you
in
you put in your code you get your key
and then you're in
i think later we'll look we're going to
look to um getting the
security codes on here as well that way
they can just open up their mobile
phones
nice yeah yeah that's nice the thing is
here's the thing right
everything's being automated yeah when
you go to a hotel
you don't need to speak to a
receptionist yeah you know
you don't need to speak to a
receptionist all you need is what does
the receptionist do
welcome here's your key off you go like
you don't need someone there oh yeah so
it's all about systemizing everything
yeah um all right cool this is nice yeah
this is one of your one bedroom
apartments there's one of our smaller
ones yeah yeah
so as you can see there's fridge washing
machine everything
um need to to cook food as well and
that's something that hotels can't
provide you with
how how long do you you usually have
guests to stay here do they stay for one
night a week or how long so it's a two
night minimum
yeah and then but we have we have guests
who have booked them for two weeks we've
got one that's in for three weeks
one that's been in for five days and
extended for another week so yeah
yeah i'm here for two nights yeah yeah
yeah
my my man darwin's here for two nights
and the thing is we booked a one bed
yeah like the same as this oh the
layout's a little bit different yeah
but but darwin was on the sofa bed this
turns into a bed yeah yeah we have
really good feedback from d
as well about how comfortable it is this
does not look that comfortable it
doesn't look it but yeah but it is going
to be deceiving though
yeah it doesn't always even as a bed you
know you
you roll this out yeah yeah it's a
comfortable bed
yeah the the double bed i noticed as
well i was in the double bed and i'm
like
this is a zip bed yeah this is a zip bed
tommy through show me show me the double
room and taught me through that so
most of them are zip beds some some are
just double yeah yeah but most
i think this is just a bubble bit yeah
but um what is a zip bed and what
why is it important so zip bit is you
can a bit that you can separate into
singles
or bring them to double so obviously if
you're with your wife like
jesse loves to sleep next to his wife
you can bring it together
but then when they fight you can
separate it you know
i mean let's say let's say me and darwin
want to book a place together yeah we we
just want to book a one room
yeah but we don't want to share a bet
yeah yeah
you could have sex
you can technically get three people
yeah one of the sofa
or you could have one person there it's
flexible yeah so when people are booking
it you can advertise it multiple ways
right
yeah which is clever we use that
strategy because a lot of our
um guests are contractors as well yeah
contractors like to be separated
yeah so yeah yeah looks like that's
right now we're contractors yeah
no no i'm here to work yeah yeah yeah
i'm a contractor right now
i don't know what he is
yeah straight with the developer you
said you had your man james come down
yeah what happened yeah so james murphy
um
he made the trip to our trip to come and
kind of
yeah talk to the developers while we're
here as well and then help us get the
deal over the line were you like
i know you've done quite a lot of
service departments prior to this yeah
were you scared going this big right
yeah what yeah
he was scared i was just not scared of
anything no
yeah but i was i was a bit hesitant but
yeah um
yeah i just i was i just had my faith in
just to jump forward with it
yeah and he's worked has worked how much
profit you expected to make
uh it always should i say is this
expensive i know you brought joint
ventures and stuff
yeah how much profit is this expected to
make every month so
70 occupancy um wolf calculated about
six to eight hundred quid a month
per per apartment so wow yeah that's
okay times that by 12. so call it 700 on
average
per apartment times 12. so you're
expected to make about eight thousand
four hundred pounds a month profit
profit yeah in total which you're going
to share with sure investors yes how
many investors you pulled in
seven seven and a half years okay cool
investors how much money did you put
into this
zero hold on how much did we put in we
put it
it's very nice as well a new build yeah
so another thing is this your first
service department
the quality was poor man yeah yeah
yeah you tried to copy me in sheffield
but you didn't quite you didn't quite
get the x factor right well yeah we've
yeah like i said before
we try to cut corners yeah and try to
not put
every everything into that apartment and
we thought we could make it work and
that's why all of our stuff is brand new
now now you
it's like shopping through the window if
you guys see something that they're
interested in
then they'll go into the shop and look
further so yeah when our properties on
on the market the pictures and the
quality of it needs to look good
and you say as well the way you speak
it sounds to me like your biggest
competitor of the hotels
yes because you keep like making little
subliminal shade at the hotels
like you look at this in a hotel even
your guests
your guests are like it's much better
than the premiere how long are you
staying here for and what's the
experience been like so far
we've been we're here for four days
experiences is perfect
exactly what we need um for the four-day
stay
nothing nothing more to say really
absolutely fantastic
how do you think it compares to premiere
in
much better than premiere if you
because we are making a lot of money
like they're making a lot of money but
we haven't got the staff
no we don't have to own the properties
it's a great business model
yeah you know can we head down to
another room or maybe even here we go we
go to another room up here yeah great
wow look at this number nine
oh yes yeah
yes yes this is this is where i wouldn't
box if
he said to me we've got no other
available
i'm like come on punk i see that's
charlotte benjamin the wives
your wives were like proper unsure at
the beginning yeah now you employ them
full time in the company
yeah they run the show they run the show
yeah they make it happen so why you guys
are doing rugby
they're running the show on the property
side of the business so we'll we'll
still go out and get deals and
view view properties and while they kind
of look after all the management side of
things we'll also
come to the what if we think that our
property is good enough for sa
then we'll bring them along to kind of
confirm it yeah yeah i think it's
interesting
you've got like an ironing board
so when the guests come it's almost like
home from home
that you can separate into singles so
you can bring them in
so you can literally just pull this
apart yeah move move the things over
yeah and then you can share a double
room yeah great stuff
yeah i love it love it love it what i
want to say as well i stayed here last
night
and i thought it was an incredible stay
yeah you know so you guys are doing an
incredible job thank you
you created a great product
another sofa bed as well so yeah you get
three people in here one on the bed
zip unzip the bed two there yeah awesome
awesome love it so when did you take
when did you take this on
three uh three weeks ago yeah yeah oh
yeah three
yeah oh sorry we got it ready three
weeks ago we took it on
about you've already got it fully pretty
much fully rented yeah yeah that's
impressive yeah which is it's been
really good so where are you taking this
now jesse this is
our two bedroom
yeah so this is how i made it two better
i love the individuality between them
they're all very different
yeah yeah so when you first advertise
this where did you stick it did you
stick it on booking.com or
where are you advertising this yeah
booking.com and airbnb
yeah and then we had some direct
bookings as well
so the first number one was the direct
booking
yeah that was straight in how did you
find them
um that one was word of mouth yeah
someone just said oh these guys are
opening
um like a hotel type of thing you know i
noticed as well
everybody knows you guys around this
area are walking to the cafe they'll be
like yeah
everyone knows you oh
[Music]
because of because of how and you even
look a bit like the rock
ponytail that's michael that's michael
no
you're not the same as well you're from
the same area right
nah he's from sydney i'm from sydney i'm
from
so just talk me through then um you know
some of the lessons through through this
project you know some of the things that
you have to look out for i just think
all the
compliances that we need you know
obviously we're good at getting the
deals and
and talking to developers and and stuff
like that but the stuff our wives are
doing now
it's probably something that we could do
systemizing check-ins
using um up listening for instance
deposits and stuff that that's something
that we we wouldn't know
especially on a scale like this we're
usually just doing one properly
but with 12 apartments in the one block
yeah that's like a whole different scale
location how close is it to the center
20 second walk literally we walked down
for breakfast this morning
yeah really really really close walk
yeah so now i love it guys you did a
great great job i'll be staying more
often for sure
yeah yeah yeah we'll just charge you
premium exactly
thank you everyone this is thailand
property i'm jesse
this is cue that's samuel let's go see
the next clip yeah you know what if
you've got questions for these guys as
well about how they got started you know
how they do rugby
alongside property um what are the
projects they've got going on
quick put questions below maybe we
should do a we'll do a full interview at
some point
yeah we can go through the whole story
if you want to see that
let us know in the comments and uh yeah
see you next time
you